gilles verdez vous avez eu candide
renard au téléphone candide qui vous a
raconté beaucoup de choses à nous dire
ce qu'elle vous a dit rld qu'on dit
c'est parti depuis début mai il n'est
question que de ça le tournage du
prochain koh lanta annulé en cause un
candidat et digby y aurait agressé
sexuellement candide renard une autre
candidate du jeu une longue bataille
judiciaire a commencé depuis entre deux
camps avec des versions bien différentes
chez des candidats les langues se
délient et certains n'hésitent pas à
critiquer le comportement de candide
pour moi quand il était un élément
provocateur si on veut mettre en avant
sa plastique c'est une autre émission
qu'il faut faire et des guyot lui même
s'est exprimé il ya plusieurs médias ils
déclarent tous les soirs j'ai dormi
entre un homme et la paroisse de la
cabane candide elle était plus loin
quand les cameramans sont revenus dans
la nuit pour nous filmer je me suis
réveillé et candide était à moitié sur
moi ça a été filmé et ça me disculper
complètement le clan candide renard se
fait quant à lui remarquer par un
silence qui n'en finit plus d'étonner
aux dernières nouvelles elle était en
état de choc post traumatique après
l'incident mais aujourd'hui candidat
contacter gilles verdez et décide enfin
de sortir du silence
alors exactement vous avez suivi la
faire koh lanta m'a dit qu'il aimerait
bien sûr c'était fou de koh lanta donc
tu j'adore volontaire et c'est vrai que
j'étais triste de ce qui s'était passé
alors ils ont aliéné le tournage de koh
lanta
alors on a rappelé un petit peu les
faits et gilles vous avez eu donc
candide renard la présumée donc victime
au téléphone
voilà je précise donc et 10 ans qui est
soupçonné de l'agression est présumé
innocent exalead faut leur dire
exactement lorsque dit qu'en dit qu'ils
n'avaient jamais parlé c'est que elle
veut absolument la confrontation avec
eddy en avait il dit parce qu'on a dit
qu'il voulait on avait dit qu'elle
refusait elle n'a jamais refusé ça c'est
faux elle dément formellement
elle a toujours voulu la confrontation
elle espère maintenant c'est à la juge
de dire quand aura lieu cette
confrontation
deuxième chose c'est que l a fait 3 des
positions une à l'aéroport juste en
arrivant une deux jours après son
arrivée et une à nancy sa version elle a
même inauguré sa version droit des
positions il y a bien eu une tentative
d'agression sexuelle absolument selon
elle bien entendu toujours c'est une
jeune fille qui est extrêmement touchée
qui a été hospitalisé qui est parti en
afrique qui lorsqu'elle sortait acheter
le pain ne pouvait plus supporter donc
là après tout ça oui après tout ça elle
ne pouvait plus supporter ce que
certains lui disais donc elle a préféré
s'isoler un moment ça a été très
difficile elle m'a raconté une scène où
son père qui est donc hervé renard un
entraîneur des faunes et blu ray est
tombé dans ses bras sa maman souffre
aussi
donc c'est très difficile alors là on a
dit aussi que les témoins de l'agression
donc les candidats de koh lanta d'accord
exonérait pour beaucoup et dit qu'ils
affirmaient la version de candide c'est
totalement faux
les témoins on est en pleine actu ont
été appelés aujourd'hui convoqué pour
aller témoigner
la coque ils n'ont pas encore témoigner
voilà donc on a dit également vous vous
souvenez que le fait qu'elle porte
plainte pouvait être une stratégie
qu'elle avait senti qu allait être
éliminé
oui eh bien c'est totalement faux selon
elle elle était la meneuse de son équipe
bleue l'équipe bleue avait gagné la
première épreuve d'immunité et au
conseil là qu'ils allaient avoir lieu
parce que les bleus avaient perdu
elle n'était absolument pas menacé donc
tout ce qui a été dit à ce niveau-là et
faux l
maintien radicalement fermement sa
version il y a bien eu viol en agression
sexuelle et elle demande elle dit je
veux que justice soit faite qu'on
respecte ma dignité
j'espère qu'il y aura un procès que
cette affaire heroes alors isabelle joue
un peu new delhi n'est question n'ont
cédé je suis sa version je la respecte
servir s'il a fait elle ne peut dire
rien d'autre que ça de toute façon donc
effectivement il faut il maintenant une
confrontation entre les deux quand tu
dis les candidats n'ont pas n'ont pas
témoigné oui ils n'ont pas témoigné
officiellement il avait fait des aveux
fait des déclarations spontanées mais
maintenant ils expliquent qu'ils ont
tous été entendus
aujourd'hui ils ont été appelés
aujourd'hui pour un rendez vous ils vont
être entendus élèves qui a demandé à
arrêter le tournage de koh lanta ou pas
oui c'est un alors voilà après il ya
l'histoire de quoi ils ont arrêté torres
qui aurait pu la faire entrer qu'elle
est dit exfiltré voilà non non on attend
longtemps vides en mai quand on l'entend
quand on l'entend quand elle raconte ce
qui s'est passé il ya des détails que
vous savez que je dis tout mais il ya
des détails qu'elle m'a demandé pas
donné donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle vous
a dit et fasquelle vous à voile a
autorisé à dire alors on la reprend lui
a reproché de ne pas avoir passé elle
même le coup de fil à la production vous
vous souvenez de ça on a indiqué ce qui
s'est passé et de ce qu'elle vous a dit
voilà donc il ya bien eu un non mais oui
il a raison de s'en aller voilà ce loin
selon elle les faits sont avérés
donc essayez bath et donc c'était
pendant la nuit quotas et après donc à
quoi c'est le cap et la production non
parce que on lui a reproché de ne pas
avoir un père production mais la
mallette pour appeler la production elle
ne pouvait pas l'atteindre parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui l'a empêché
d'atteindre cette mallette
donc c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui a
rappelé voilà elle n'a pas pu elle-même
passé le coup de fil pour l'airé
intentionnel pardon de manière
intentionnelle ou la veille avait pris
la valette
oui on l'a empêché elle n'a pas pu
passer le coup de fil qu'elle aurait
voulu passer donc c'est quelqu'un qui a
passé scotché la production et ça a été
arrêté lors de laquelle oncle à aller
dans quelles dispositions
j'ai senti à sa voix à quelqu'un de très
lucide très intelligent mais extrêmement
touchée et ayant envie de rétablir sa
vérité et disons que la partie adverse
communiquer énormément
elle ne veut pas prendre officiellement
la parole mais je pense qu'elle avait
envie que son message soit entendu
c'est une jeune fille qui souffre
énormément j'ai trouvé vous gardez très
longuement
j'ai trouvé qu'elle souffrait beaucoup
merci merci gilbert baisse pour ces
infos voilà sur koh lanta on vous en
dira plus et donc ils ont tous été
entendus aujourd'hui on aura donc
d'autres nouvelles demain puisque on
vous dira un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé